[Music]
hi
mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american dystopian action
film called chaos walking
spoilers ahead watch out and take
[Music]
care the movie is set on a planet far
far away from earth called the new world
a planet where the sun never sets it is
the year 2258 a.d
searching for a better life some humans
left earth and colonized a part of the
planet humans have found everything they
had back on earth and more in the new
world when humans first entered the new
planet they realized that all men have
been afflicted with a condition called
the noise this condition causes everyone
to see and hear a man's thoughts
although this condition lays bare one's
secret thoughts and hence can be a
disadvantage especially for teenage boys
one can do other cool things like
creating 3d holograms using their noise
which others can see with their naked
eyes the human colonists were involved
in a bitter civil war with the native
humanoid species referred to as the
spackle in the war the spackle
ostensibly killed all the female human
colonists while half the men survived
since then the first wave of human
colonists lost contact with the earth
and the outside world
todd hewitt is a young man who lives in
the human colony called prentice town
todd lost his mother and father at a
young age in the war and lives with his
adoptive fathers ben moore and killian
boyd unlike his fathers todd has never
seen a woman he spends most of his time
helping his fathers in the field
one day he aspires to be a man like the
colony's mayor david prentice unlike
other men prentice has mastered the art
of controlling his noise making his
thoughts difficult to see and hear other
prominent residents of the town include
the eccentric preacher aaron and david
prentice's son davey todd doesn't see
eye to eye with davey as both always
compete to win the mayor's approval one
day the second wave of human colonists
arrive onboard a mothership they send a
small scout ship carrying three human
crew members to investigate the planet
and make contact with the first wave of
human colonists unfortunately upon
entering new world's atmosphere the
scout ship catches fire and crashes deep
in the woods near prentice town while
helping his dad todd spots someone
stealing food from his barn he chases
the thief into the woods with his dog
manche he eventually loses the thief but
comes across the crash site he
speculates that the survivor must have
been the thief he immediately rushes to
inform the mayor about the spaceship on
his way he tries to keep quiet but the
other men hear and see his thoughts
about the crashed ship and they all had
to investigate the crash scene and
scavenge some parts of the ship after
learning that the survivor didn't have
any noise mayor prentice concludes that
it must be a girl and orders his men to
look for her while todd is alone the
girl reveals herself todd is scared
shocked and enchanted to see a girl as
he has never seen one before but unable
to control his noise todd
unintentionally alerts the town dwellers
to her whereabouts the girl runs deeper
into the woods but prentice surrounds
her with a 3d hologram cage and captures
her prentice takes her to his home and
expresses his condolences to her over
the loss of the other two crew members
the girl learns about the noise and the
war with the spackle which resulted in
the massacre of all women of prentice
town prentice asks her about her mission
and she tells him that she came here on
a scout ship sent by the mother ship to
make contact with the first wave
colonies the mother ship is the largest
ship in the second colonist's fleet and
holds four thousand people it will soon
come to rescue her the girl starts
getting suspicious of prentice's
intention when he keeps pressing her
more about the ship inquiring about its
landing site and time prentice is
suddenly forced to go outside to address
the men who are creating a lot of noise
and burning with curiosity about the
female guest before leaving davey is
charged with keeping an eye on her the
spoiled brat starts going through the
girl's bag and unwittingly toys with one
of her gadgets which causes it to shoot
sparks helping her disappear while
escaping the girl overhears prentice
talking to the town's influential
preacher aaron from under the
floorboards prentice says he is fed up
with living in exile he plans to seize
her colony's mothership and use it to
take over the rest of the planet he says
they must prevent her from contacting
and warning the mothership meanwhile the
preacher is convinced that the girl is
an angel descended from heaven to punish
the man of princess town for their sins
as prentice and others venture out to
look for the girl todd steals the girl's
bag from the mayor's home hoping to find
some cool stuff be careful what you wish
for todd after returning home todd
starts going through the bag but to his
surprise he finds the girl hiding in his
barn suddenly one of prentice's men
comes looking for the girl after
spotting her jacket nearby todd lets the
girl hide and sends the man away ben and
killian learn about the girl and lock
her in the barn they tell their son he
must give the girl back to prentice to
avoid attracting any trouble but todd
refuses to comply todd has started
liking the girl and insists on helping
her ben and killian eventually relent
releasing this might be the only chance
todd will get of starting his own family
ben tells todd to take the girl to far
branch another human town on the planet
which todd never knew existed killian
worries that people there are hostile to
prentistown men but ben assures him that
they won't harm todd as long as the girl
accompanies him but before todd could
leave with the girl prentice and his men
arrive looking for her the girl escapes
on a motorcycle while todd chases after
her on a horse
upset it todd for hiding the girl
prentice kills killian giving ben a
chance to save his own and todd's life
prentice then asks him to help find todd
and the girl todd eventually catches up
to the girl after losing their
motorcycle and horse to an accident they
both set out on foot too far branch
accompanied by todd's dog along their
journey todd finally gets to know a girl
he is amazed by her strength and at
times finds himself struggling to keep
up with her speed she initially doesn't
trust him but todd eventually wins her
trust and hunts a snake for lunch for
her ooh a new world delicacy she finally
tells todd that her name is viola she
was born on the mother ship and her
parents died during the 64-year long
journey from earth to the new world
viola's grandparents signed up for the
journey hoping to find better
opportunities on the far away planet
on route to far branch todd is attacked
by a spackle todd subdues the spackle
and proceeds to kill it but viola
teaches him kindness and asks him to let
it go they arrive at far branch and
learn that it is inhabited by men women
and children they are greeted by the
town's mayor hildy unaware of far
branch's dislike for prentice town viola
discloses that todd is from prentiss
town todd is immediately put in
handcuffs while hildy talks to viola in
private the town's men confront todd but
after talking to viola the mayor tells
them to back off prentice and his men
continue to pursue todd and the girl
preacher aaron is becoming increasingly
unstable and at times clashes with
prentice mayor hildy gives todd and
viola shelter and food she also tells
them that viola can make contact with
her mothership from haven the first
human settlement in the new world which
todd didn't know about either viola
decides to head for haven the next
morning seeing her so adamant about
leaving todd starts wondering what if
viola stayed with him and kissed him
instead i'd rather be with you kiss me
talk to me of course viola hears his
thoughts and todd embarrassed apologizes
honestly that could have been a lot
worse after dinner hildy gives them
separate rooms to rest but the thought
of viola leaving doesn't let todd sleep
he finds his mother's journal that ben
put in his bag and shows it to viola who
also is still awake viola asks him what
his mother has written and todd reveals
that he doesn't know because he can't
read prentice town's mayor aaron burned
all the books when todd was a child he
felt that being born with a noise was
enough of an education viola offers to
read it for todd todd's mother's name is
carissa carissa writes my dearest todd i
begin this journal on the day of your
birth you're the most beautiful thing
i've seen in new world i wish your paw
were here to see you but the lord saw
fit to take him you're going to be tall
strong and handsome like your paw the
ladies of new world won't know what hit
him there's a man named david prentice
who convinced us all to find a
settlement on the far side of the swamp
so that the noise from the rest of the
new world won't reach us prentice seems
so full of secrets and shame and this
place doesn't allow that he's better at
making his noise disappear than any man
here it's so loud here all the time the
men can't stand women knowing everything
about them and them not knowing anything
about us almost all the men here they're
breaking down prentice and aaron are
getting inside the men's heads they've
given all of us women a curfew the men
are turning on us aaron our holy man
said women don't have noise because
we've got no souls i can see what's
coming clear as day if things go wrong
keep searching for hope todd realizes
that the women were not killed by the
native aliens but rather by prentice and
the men of prentistone he feels angry
and betrayed that everything he had been
told was a lie prentice and his men
arrive at far branch demanding viola
hildy and other far branch town dwellers
distract them while todd and viola try
to escape preacher aaron discovers them
forcing them to hide inside a storeroom
a far branch woman helps them keep aaron
and other men away with a rifle prentice
sends ben to convince todd to surrender
viola in exchange for sparing todd's
life todd confronts ben about the
journal ben admits that he tried but
couldn't do anything to help the women
it was chaos the best he could do was
keep todd safe ben apologizes to him for
keeping him in the dark and tells todd
let me protect you now prentice gives
ben and todd an ultimatum to bring the
girl out ben appears from the store
followed by viola as she proceeds
towards prentice he tells her he is
pleased to see her again but to prentice
and other men's astonishment viola
suddenly disappears into thin air it was
a 3d hologram noise created by ben to
distract prentice and others while the
real viola todd and manche fled from the
back door however preacher aaron spots
them and starts chasing them they come
across a boat and escape through the
river aaron continues to pursue them and
knocks them over the boat todd manages
to save and get away with viola but
unfortunately the psychopath aaron kills
manche further enraging todd manchi's
death extremely upsets todd but viola
comforts him and they continue on their
journey to haven the support towers for
a monorail built by first wave colonists
show them the path on their way viola
and todd come across the ruins of the
first colony ship prentice and his men
begin to catch up with them todd
suggests they keep moving but viola
tells him that they don't have much time
left and they can use the ship's
emergency transmitter they scan the
ruins and eventually find the
transmitter but viola learns that the
antenna is damaged viola loses hope but
todd offers to repair it he climbs on
the antenna and asks viola to be on
standby to send the signal todd manages
to fix the antenna as prentice and his
men arrive with ben prentiss threatens
to kill ben should todd not surrender
but ben tells his son not to cave in to
his demand meanwhile preacher aaron
sneaks into the ship and attacks viola
aaron regrets killing the women of
prentice town he laments not being able
to tell the voice of god from the noise
he believes he is a sinner and pleads
with viola to kill him and purify him
left with no choice viola immolates
aaron with one of her gadgets as he
burns the preacher exclaims i am
baptized with fire i'm the sinner and
passes away viola then sends the sos
signal to the mother ship while todd
surrenders himself before prentice
prentice asks todd about the girl but
this time todd manages to hide his noise
angered prentice shoots his father and
todd immediately rushes to ben's side
ben again apologizes to todd for keeping
him in the dark about his mother and
slips him a knife before passing away
todd attacks prentice with the knife but
he is sent rolling down losing the knife
in the process todd runs for cover but
prentice wounds him with the gun todd
then sneaks up on prentice from behind
only to realize that he is an illusion
prentice then proceeds to shoot him but
todd distract him with an illusion of
his mother and other women of prentice
town all calling him a coward they back
prentice up on the edge of a cliff viola
then appears and attacks him with a pipe
he dodges the strike and grabs the pipe
but loses his balance in the process
viola then frees her grip and prentice
falls to his death as viola tends to a
badly wounded todd the colony mothership
arrives causing davy and the remaining
prentice town men to flee in fear todd
later gains consciousness in the
mothership's medical room fully healed
with viola by his side viola reveals
that she is going to live in the new
world with him and takes him to meet the
other colonists maybe they'll have
little spider-man skywalker babies and
there will be a sequel subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching